on the sweeney amendment as amended all
those in favor say aye
all those opposed no in the opinion of
the chairs the eyes have it and the
amendment is agreed to for what purpose
does the gentleman from new york rise mr
chairman move the strike the last word
the
gentleman has an amendment you seek to
do that
okay correct would you like to offer the
amendment at the time this time i would
like the opportunity to explain it
okay
okay the gentleman's recognized for five
minutes
thank you very much mr chairman
mr chairman because of uh recent
activities by
a certain member of the spanish
judiciary
the attention of the world has once
again been directed
at the events which took place in chile
beginning in september of 1973
with the assassination of the duly
elected president of that country
salvador allende
and the subsequent ascension to power
of
general augusto pinochet to become the
president
of the republic of chile
in the uh course of those events
it has been alleged
in responsible venues
over and over again in the intervening
now more than 25 years
that
very inappropriate actions were taken
by members of the chilean
military
assisted by others including
members of the military of the united
states
i have an amendment
which requires
that no later than 120 days after the
date of the enactment of this act
the director of the central intelligence
agency shall submit to the appropriate
congressional committees which are
mentioned in the amendment
a report describing all activities of
officers covert agents and employees of
all elements in the intelligence
community with respect to the following
events in the republic of chile
one the assassination of president
salvador allende in september of 1973
to the ascension of general augusto
pinochet to the presidency of the
republic of chile
and three violations of human rights
committed by officers or agents of
former
president pinochet
the report submitted under this
subsection shall include copies of
unedited documents in the possession
of any such element of the intelligence
community with respect to such events
mr chairman i think that after the
passage of all of this time
it is appropriate
that
the united states congress and the
people of the united states and the
people of the world understand with much
greater clarity than they have been able
to up to this moment
the specific events which took place
in chile
which led to the assassination of the
duly elected president and the ascension
of power
by a military junta
it is important for us to understand
these events because it's important for
us to take action to ensure that these
kinds of illegal activities do not
occur
in the future
and so therefore i offer this amendment
with all respect in the hopes
that the members of the house and the
chairman particularly the chairman of
the intelligence committee will see fit
to uh
look upon it favorably i yield back
someone yields back the bounds of his
time just to be clear the gentleman from
new york intends that his amendment be
pending at this time i the chair
understood you were just striking the
last word you intend to offer the
amendment at this time
i offer the amendment at this point okay
the clerk will designate the amendment
amendment number four offered by mr
hinchey of new york
the
gentleman from florida for what purpose
do you rise i believe to strike the last
word gentleman is recognized for five
minutes
i thank the chairman
i appreciate the the intent
of the amendment very much but i must
say i have some misgivings about the
effect
and the cost and i want to take a minute
to explain them
first
with regard to the purpose let me say
that our our committee is trying i think
through its mark on the budget and
through its oversight
to help our intelligence community focus
on the challenges we've got today and
coming in the next century and and they
are
incredible challenges of a sort that we
are really not organized to deal with as
we are seeing unfortunately we're in the
process of getting that done
but we we understand the warsaw pact is
gone
in its place we've got the osama bin
ladens the milosevic it's the tijuana
cartels that type of problem
this amendment would i think have us
take a break from the the reality we're
faced with today
uh and go back and start sifting through
some history
uh that
of things that happened at a different
time really under a different agency
that was operating under different rules
and certainly under different oversight
now that can be beneficial
uh
if it
is going to yield us some lessons
but i think we ought to understand that
if we're going to do this it's going to
take energy and effort in dollars
and we want to make sure where we're
prioritizing those uh relative to the
lessons from history uh and whatever
else we might glean from this effort
i'm a little confused
to the extent of ongoing effort by the
administration to respond to a request
by the spanish government
under its mutual legal assistance treaty
with the u.s for documents
roughly the same
period i presume these searches are
related but i don't know
whether there is any formal
coordination
and how this amendment would fit into it
going to the cost factor legislation
directing special searches as i've said
is disruptive to the normal course of
business and the normal course of this
business of business and the
intelligence communities these days
is exceptionally challenging
um i would also point out that when we
have these special searches that they
sometimes delay requests of our own um
constituents under the freedom of
information act i don't say that to say
that we shouldn't have special requests
i think we only need to point out that
that sometimes happens and we have had
considerable conversation with the
head of the community the intelligence
community about how we go about dealing
with the classification declassif
declassification process
and that is ongoing and there is very
definite bona fide concern about how
much dollar and time and personnel
we direct to that effort relative to
other things that the intelligence
community is being asked to provide for
today's decision makers to get us
through the day
and of course we have to figure out
where does the money come from
these are not new thoughts i'm only
putting these on the record and getting
them out of there because i don't want
you to think uh that we are just uh
knee-jerk reacting negatively i'm not
there are negative consequences to this
amendment in part
the amendment would provide no new
information to the public as far as i
know
um
the people who are interested in the
abuses of the pinochet years
i i think instead we're going to get
lots of boxes going into a closed
committee review and i'm not sure
whether it's going to lead us
so i am concerned
about
if the purpose is to get it the truth
and the history and where we're doing it
i would like to do that in a reasonable
way i share the gentleman's desire to do
that if the
way we can do it
passes muster
with the community
and the costs are reasonable and the
expectations are reasonable given the
personnel that we have
then i would possibly be in a position
to accept
this
amendment
with those understandings so i would be
prepared to yield the gentleman and
would ask to the gentleman to accept a
second-degree amendment which would
which would strike sub-section b-2
of the proposed section 0-3 excuse me
section 304 in its entirety
if so and the house agreed to the
amendment
uh amending your amendment in that way i
would accept your amendment and the
reason i say that
uh
is this the amendment i would propose
would cure the constitutional problem
that i see in the provision which would
have overridden all the laws authorizing
the dci and the president to protect
sources and methods and national
security information from disclosure and
compromise and we just accepted an
amendment from mr hinchey of
mr sweeney of new york
to strengthen that so i don't want to
now turn right around and undercut it so
with the offending provision emitted
uh any threat of the veto would be
removed we would be consistent and i
think i could see my way to supporting
what you're trying to get done
i yield to the gentleman for response on
my proposal
uh i thank the gentleman as i understand
it uh you are offering an amendment to
to my amendment which would strike
paragraph two
of section 304 b
as proposed to be added by the amendment
is that correct the gentleman will yield
that's correct the gentleman's time is
expired i ask unanimous cent to continue
continue for an additional moment is
there objection if not the gentleman's
recognized
thank you uh that is correct i yield
back i i thank the the gentleman the
chairman of the committee and i'm happy
to accept his amendment to my amendment
uh mr chairman i would like to offer my
secondary amendment i have it at the
desk the clerk will report the secondary
amendment an amendment offered by mr
goss of florida to the amendment
numbered four offered by mr hinchey of
new york strike paragraph two of section
304 b
as proposed to be added by the amendment
thank you mr chairman that's the
amendment we've had the discussion i
have nothing further yield back the
gentleman yields back for what purpose
is generally from california rise
consent to strike the last word
gentlelady is recognized for five
minutes i rise in support of the hinchey
amendment and commando the distinguished
chairman of our committee for his
accommodation of mr hinchey's amendment
but i want this amendment to survive the
conference because i think mr hinchey
has provided some
great leadership
to us today in presenting this amendment
and that's why i'm very grateful to the
chairman for his amendment to
accommodate mr hinchey
mr our distinguished chairman laid out
some important
considerations in in in his uh
observation of this uh this amendment
and they are important there are other
equities to be balanced and i'm glad
that you've come to uh agreement on the
amendment but again i wanted to survive
the conference and i want to commend
mr hinchey
our president was in guatemala a few
months ago or was it weeks so much
happened so fast around here and i was
very proud of the statement that he made
latin america had been in turmoil for a
couple of generations as we all know
some of it sad to say and in guatemala
in particular
with the involvement
of the central intelligence agency and
other american
entities there
the president i think very courageously
recognized what happened there
and in doing so i think began
to open the door to a better future
for the intelligence community
in central america and in latin america
the expression
is so famous because in argentina in
chile and central america countries are
revisiting their um
sad recent past and important bridge to
the future have been truth commissions
which have identified
not to find revenge but to seek some
level of justice and some level of
openness about admission about what
happened
and
to clear the way for the future
if we the united states and the central
intelligence agency had a role
in the death of of president allende
just as if anybody else had a role in it
putting it behind us requires facing the
truth about it and so i think that as
far as chile is concerned
this is a very important amendment but i
think it also will build credibility for
us if we're not in a state of denial
about the cia's involvement but of
acceptance of what the reality was and
we'll find out what that is as a result
of mr
hinchey's amendment i also uh though i
want to say that
that unless
we are not forthcoming on our role it's
very hard to see why
latin americans
will be forthcoming about what their
role is and i think we can lead by
example in this way i also would like to
take the occasion to thank george miller
for his leadership and his activity in
persuading our and trying to persuade
our government and making the documents
available uh for the pinochet uh case uh
to the spanish uh government and and
hope that this will be a message
uh to repressive dictators everywhere
that a day of reckoning comes and that
you just cannot
commit these atrocities
and
and uh and then say well let's put it
all behind us as i say again this is not
about revenge it's about truth it's
about justice it's about lead opening
the way uh for a better future and
building credibility for for what we do
i agree with the chairman we should not
we should not jeopardize the safety of
our sources and methods and i think that
his amendment is a constructive one
these people risk their lives just the
way our young people do in the military
we're proud of the military we're proud
of the people who put themselves in harm
way to gather intelligence up for us
so while we're not condoning any
activities which we will
we will find out what they were but uh
that were not legal uh there are
we cannot proceed with a reasonable
intelligence gathering if if those were
called are called upon to do so
uh are are in jeopardy because some of
unintentional um
identification
especially at a time when we want more
women we want more minorities we want
more diversity more language skills we
want more cultural understanding into
the central intelligence agency we want
them to have the same level of
protection that others have had in the
past and and building that diversity
with an openness and admission of of
what our past has been i think will
build more support for what we need to
have which is the best possible
intelligence to avoid conflict and to
supply whoever the president of the
united states is with the information he
needs to lead with that again i commend
mr hinchey and our chairman and our
ranking member for their leadership on
this issue
thank you ladies time has expired
for what purpose does the
gentleman of california rise
mr chairman strike the last word i think
the gentleman from new york is
absolutely correct with this amendment
the minority has no problem with
deal back the balance
what purpose does the gentleman from
vermont rise i moved to strike last word
gentleman's recognized for five minutes
i want to applaud mr hinchey on his
amendment
it is no great secret that over the
years there have been many aspects of
american foreign policy which have been
wrong
uh it is no secret that the united
states over the years has been involved
in the overthrow of a number of
democratic governments
in the case of chile in 1973 there was a
democratic government elected by the
people the president of that government
was salvador allende his policies
antagonized corporate interest in the
united states and a great deal of
pressure was brought to bear in seeing
him overthrown and i think it is a very
positive step as we develop ideas for
the future as we try to develop a
democratic foreign policy that we in
fact know what we did in the past so i
think mr hinchey's amendment is an
important one i think we should let the
truth come out and i strongly support
his efforts i would yield back the
balance of my gentleman yields back his
time does any other member wish to be
heard on the pending amendment if not
the question occurs on the gos amendment
to the hinchey amendment all those in
favor say aye
all those know in the opinion of the
chair of the eyes have it the eyes have
it and the question now occurs on the
hinchey amendment as amended all those
in favor shall say aye
all those opposed no when the opinion of
the chairs of the eyes have it the
amendment is agreed to for what purpose
does the gentleman from georgia rise the
chairman i have an amendment at the desk
designated as amendment number two is
pre-printed in the congressional record
the clerk will designate the amendment
amendment number two offered by mr barr
of georgia mr chairman i ask unanimous
consent that the men might be considered
as red without objection so ordered the
gentleman is recognized for five minutes
in support of his amendment thank you mr
chairman mr chairman i had the honor of
serving this great land back in the
1970s uh including those years in in
which the
government of our country in an effort
to institutionalize proper oversight of
our intelligence agencies enacted public
laws that established the house
permanent select committee on
intelligence and the senate select
committee on intelligence in the
intervening generation these committees
including under the current leadership
of chairman goss
have provided very very essential
oversight of the intelligence activities
of our government
hopefully in so doing we have avoided
any excesses that have given rise to
some of the incidents in the past that
have troubled our intelligence gathering
capabilities and hurt the credibility of
these great institutions such as the cia
however mr chairman
the
oversight with which mr goss and many
others have worked so diligently to both
implement and then preserve over the
last 24 years
is is under attack right now and the
survivability of that oversight
mechanism is threatened i speak
particularly mr chairman of efforts by
the
intelligence community to deny proper
information for the house permanent
select committee on intelligence
to conduct oversight meaningful
oversight responsibilities for example
in recent communications between the
chairman and the nsa the general counsel
of the nsa interposed
what by any stretch of the imagination
is a bogus claim of executive or not
executive but attorney-client privilege
in an effort to deny the chairman and
the committee members proper information
with which to carry out their oversight
responsibilities
in particular the chairman was seeking
very important information that goes to
the standards whereby the intelligence
community and the agencies comprising
the intelligence community
gather intelligence
and gather information
on american citizens
one such project in particular that has
recently come to light mr chairman is a
project known as project echelon
which has been in place for several
years and which by accounts that we have
recently seen in the media
engages in the interception of literally
millions of communications involving
united states citizens over
over satellite transmissions involving
email transmissions internet access
as well as mobile phone communications
and telephone
communications
and this information apparently is
shared at least in part and coordinated
at least in part with intelligence
agencies of four other countries the uk
canada new zealand and australia as part
of our effort here in the congress both
on the intelligence committee with which
uh which mr goss chairs as well as
others of us while not serving on that
committee are concerned about the
privacy rights of american citizens and
whether or not
there are constitutional safeguards
being circumvented by the manner in
which the intelligence agencies are
intercepting
and or receiving international
communications back from foreign nations
that would otherwise be prohibited by
the prohibitions and the limitations on
the collection of domestic intelligence
we have been trying to get information
with regard to project echelon and
others the amendment that i propose
today simply would require the
intelligence community and that is
specifically the department of justice
the national security agency and the cia
to provide to the congress within 60
days of the enactment of this
intelligence authorization act a report
setting forth the legal basis and
procedures whereby the intelligence
community and the agencies comprising
the intelligence community
gather intelligence this will enable the
intelligence community and the judiciary
committees of both houses to properly
evaluate whether or not
these procedures are being implemented
properly according to proper legal and
constitutional standards it would be
very interesting to see
mr chairman if the administration or the
senate
opposes this very straightforward
amendment which simply requires a report
on the legal basis for such
interceptions to be furnished within 60
days to the intelligence committees of
both houses and to the judiciary
committees of both houses
i ask members on both sides of the aisle
to support this very straightforward
amendment which not only will help
guarantee the privacy rights of american
citizens but will protect
the oversight responsibilities of the
congress which are now under assault by
these bogus claims that the intelligence
communities are making uh and i ask the
adoption of the amendment
gentleman yields back the balance of his
time from what i yield to the
distinguished chairman of the committee
uh mr goss from florida well does the
gentleman seek recognition on his own uh
i moved to strike the last version
now for five minutes bounce my time
uh thank you mr chairman i uh i want to
say i very much appreciate a
distinguished gentleman from george's
remarks he has characterized a ongoing
vigilance of oversight matter that we
carry on every day i am certainly
prepared to accept his amendment i think
it is useful
uh and indeed helpful
to some problems we're having directly
now
i also think that it is helpful in the
area of the very
delicate balancing act that we have to
do on hipsie and i hope we do it well i
think we do it well
it is on the one hand absolutely
accepting no compromise on the rights of
american citizens and on the other hand
not tying the hands of our law
enforcement people
who are trying to catch people who are
trying to work mischief against the
united states of america and uh it is
not always as clear as it might be uh
which which it is uh at the beginning of
a process involving individuals so this
is a very difficult judgment area for us
nobody would want us particularly in
light of the news coming out of the
weapons labs today to release or relax
uh our efforts to catch people who are
trying to steal our secrets or penetrate
our
appropriately applied security
arrangements
on the other hand it is intolerable to
think of the united states government of
big brother or anybody else
invading the privacy of an american
citizen
without cause and uh i believe that the
gentleman from georgia's amendments will
uh will help in that debate and i am
prepared to accept them i know they're
offered in that spirit and i know that
they will also be helpful to me and my
current uh problems uh making sure the
intelligence community understands that
um
penetrating oversight is here to stay i
think most of them are getting the
message i thank the gentleman i yield
back the balance of my time what purpose
does the gentleman from california rise
strike the last word gentleman's
recognized for five minutes the minority
will accept this amendment
gentleman yields back the balance of his
time does any other member wish to be
heard on the bar amendment if not the
question occurs on the amendment offered
by the gentleman from georgia mr barr
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed no in the opinion the
chairs the eyes have it and the
amendment is agreed to are there further
amendments to title three
if not the clerk will designate title
four
page ten line twelve title four central
intelligence agency are there amendments
to title four
if not the clerk will designate title
five
page ten line nineteen title five
department of defense intelligence
activities are there amendments to title
5
are there remaining amendments to the
bill for what purpose does the gentleman
from vermont rise mr chairman i have an
amendment at the desk it's amendment
number eight in the may 12 1999
congressional record a clerk will
designate the amendment amendment number
eight offered by mr sanders of vermont
a gentleman from vermont is recognized
for five minutes in support of his
amendment thank you very much mr
chairman
uh this amendment is basically about two
issues
number one the issue is about priorities
and how we spend
our national wealth
and second secondly the issue is about
accountability and what we do when an
agency is not performing up to the level
that we want it to perform
mr chairman it is no secret
that in our great country
we are spending large sums of money
where we should not be spending it
and we are not spending money where we
should be spending it
today in the united states 43 million
americans have no health insurance
but we don't have the money to help
those people today in the united states
millions of senior citizens cannot
afford their prescription drugs and they
suffer and they die
because the united states government
does not do what other countries around
the world do and help seniors with their
prescription drugs
today in the united states at va
hospitals all over this country veterans
who have put their lives on the line
defending this country are not getting
the quality of care they need because
the united states congress is not
adequately funding the veterans
administration
i believe that within that context and
the fact that we are underfunding many
other important social needs we should
not be increasing funding for the
intelligence agencies and what this
amendment basically says is that we
should level fund the intelligence
agencies that's the first reason but the
second part of this amendment is equally
important
and here we are talking about
accountability and responsibility on the
part of our intelligence agencies i know
and you know that almost by definition
much of what the intelligent agencies do
is quiet i expect they do a lot of good
work which we do not hear about and i
applaud them for what they do which is
positive but it is no secret that an
area after area there have been major
deficiencies and very very poorly
performed operations and it is important
that we talk about that and that we
demand accountability
and let me just give you a few of the
examples that i think need to be talked
about and that we need from the director
of the cia and understanding of how
these things occurred and an
understanding that they will never occur
again everybody in the congress and
everybody in the united states was
shocked when we heard recently about the
bombing of the chinese embassy in
belgrade
and many of us at first thought well it
was a mistake
the pilot
aimed for another building and he hit
the chinese embassy and those things
happen it's terrible but it was a
mistake but then we learned that the
pilot hit what he was supposed to hit
and that was altogether shocking
and we found that information which was
available virtually on the world wide
web which was probably available in the
yugoslavian telephone directory that the
chinese embassy was located at that
location was apparently not available to
the cia
and their action has caused a major
international crisis
and we want to know how that mistake
could have taken place
furthermore
as someone who has been involved in the
issue of gulf war illness i and i know
all of our members
are concerned about the explosion that
took place
in
kamacia
which where the united states blew up an
iraqi
arms depot which contained chemical
weapons let me quote from the april 12
1997 new york times
quote the report issued this week by the
c i a shows that the agency actually had
detailed information including
geographical coordinates during the war
to suggest the chemical weapons are at
kamisia
information that was not passed on to
the soldiers who later blew up the depot
and may have been exposed to nerve gas
end of quote in other words our soldiers
were exposed to nerve gas because the
cia did not communicate the information
that it had
thirdly we are all familiar with the
terrible accident that took place in
italy regarding an american plane
that went into lines that keep
the gondola uh moving in a ski area let
me quote from newsday
quotes this is february 1st 1999
although the gondola had been
transversing the ski area for 30 years
there was no hint of it on the prowler's
crew map while the horizontal hazard to
aviation it was clearly marked on
italian air force charts the pentagon
agency somehow missed it end of quote so
the our intelligence agencies were not
providing our pilots with an up-to-date
map
and if they had a terrible accident
could have been avoided mr chairman
these are just three examples the fact
of the matter is there are many more
but it seems to me that in light of
their track record there is no reason
why this body should not pass i would
ask unanimous consent for one more
minute please is there objection
the gentleman's recognized it seems to
me that in light of these instances and
many more which i have not gone into
there is no reason why this body should
not pass this conservative simple
amendment
we are calling as part of this amendment
for a study of these three specific
events and we are also requesting
recommendations from the intelligence
community as to how these catastrophes
could be avoided in the future so that's
what this amendment does it says level
fund and second of all we want some
accountability on the a part of the
intelligence agency and uh i thank uh my
colleagues
for what purpose does the gentleman
california rise mr chairman i have an
amendment at the desk the clerk will
report the amendment
an amendment offered by mr dixon of
california to the amendment offered